hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll and we're continuing today with
our series on ideas about quantum field
theory quantum field theory counted as
one big idea but when we talked about it
we didn't get very far quantum field
theory is a gigantic extremely rich
subject but it's worth devoting a few
videos to it because it's the best
description of the universe of reality
at a deep level that we currently have
it might not be the final description
but it's a pretty good one and so far so
we talked first about field theory in
the sense that you take a field you
quantize it we showed how in the simple
case where those fields were free where
they were non interacting it looks like
a collection of particles and then we
did a video on interactions Fineman
diagrams where we showed how to think of
those systems of particles as
interacting with each other
turning into other particles and
actually calculate the probability of
that happening that was good news
everything was really really good and in
fact a procedure is what we use in
particle physics to actually calculate
things at the Large Hadron Collider and
elsewhere but there is a lurking problem
there so we have to go to today's topic
renormalization now the idea of
renormalization often gets glossed
defined as hiding the infinities I'll
mention that there are infinitely big
quantities that show up when you do
quantum field theory in a
straightforward way we have to get rid
of them since the physical quantities we
measure are not infinite but that's kind
of an old-fashioned way of thinking
about what renormalization is these days
we have a more modern perspective on it
the perspective is not actually that
modern in that it comes from Ken Wilson
in the 1970s and goes under the name of
effective field theories but it's taken
a while for people to catch on but this
is a better way of thinking about
renormalization so let me mention why
you get renormalization in the first
place and the idea is that you get
infinities from doing Fineman diagrams
Lyman diagrams were the calculational
tool that we used to actually calculate
the likelihood that if two particles
come together they will turn into
different collections of particles and
we said that any one process is given by
a sum of
climbing diagrams so very roughly we
have some process where two things come
in there's a blob two things go out for
example and we said well this is a sum
of Fineman diagrams maybe here's a
Fineman diagram we're gonna forget
details about electrons and photons and
all that stuff we're just gonna focus in
on some simple scalar fields for this
lecture so you have maybe a diagram like
that and then you have more complicated
diagrams with more vertices more lines
in them and then there's an infinite
number more okay and we said that these
diagrams are not just pictures of
processes there are actually
calculational tools we use them to
assign numbers that then add up to give
you the amplitude for a certain kind of
process and the hope was that as the
diagram has become more complicated the
numbers that you calculate using them
become smaller that's because every
vertex in the diagram is associated with
the square root of alpha in this case
and actually not in this case in the
electromagnetic magnetism case so alpha
is a small number so the more powers of
alpha the smaller the overall
contribution of the diagram becomes
except that there's another subtlety
that makes the second diagram that we've
drawn infinitely big so this number this
this diagram that we drew has the
feature that there are no loops inside
of it okay we have a label for diagrams
like that these are called tree diagrams
it looks like the branches of a little
tree coming out this diagram you can go
in a loop around the internal legs of
the diagram there's a closed loop that
you can describe which doesn't exist in
the first one so we call these loop
diagrams and what happens is tree
diagrams are indeed finite but loop
diagrams can become infinite and the
reason has to do with the fact that
these virtual particles that we draw on
the inside of the diagram they're not
really particles it's a story that we
tell each other and there's a certain
amount of energy that is flowing through
them as we discussed so for the tree
diagram for example you might say if you
just draw this simple diagram like this
just try to expand it to follow the
energy going through you have D 1 e 2
III efore and there's some energy that
goes through let's say in this direction
you pick the direction up to you that's
a convention and by that convention we
would call this what are we going to
call it e bar is an energy and then you
know that e 1 equals e 3 plus 8 bar and
then you can go through e 2 plus e bar
equals oops that's a 4 e 4 and then you
get a specific answer in in both cases
you know exactly what a bar is and
together you figure out that energy
better be conserved
II won plus e 2 equals e 3 plus e 4 and
can get that there yes and E bar is
given by either one of these equations
II won - III or e 4 - E - ok but the
point is there's no ambiguity there's no
freedom a bar is at a certain mount of
energy that goes down the diagram once
you know the moment of the particles you
started with he wanted me to the
energies and you know the energies of
the particles to come out by the way I
sometimes mix up the words energy
momentum because in relativity as we
discussed before there's really not just
a three-dimensional momentum there's a
four-dimensional momentum and the energy
is part of the momentum and it's related
to the spatial momentum by energy
squared equals three-dimensional anthem
squared plus the mass squared of the
particle so energy is not independent so
sometimes physicists use energy momentum
both to mean the same concept of what's
going down the legs anyway given the
fact that both energy momentum are
conserved in this diagram the value of E
bar and the corresponding value of P bar
is momentum are just fixed there's
nothing ambiguous about them you know
what they are try to do the same thing
with the loop diagram and you run into a
little bit of trouble so let's try to do
this for a loop diagram draw let's say
this box that we've been drawing for a
loop diagram ok label things e 1 e 2
III be four and we'll have the energies
go this way this way this way as before
down
right right right and then up just to
complete the loop there and if you call
this top one see when II one splits into
two different lines neither one of these
lines is anchored neither one of these
lines escapes the diagram neither one of
these lines gives you a momentum or an
energy that you will measure so in
principle you say let's let a bar some
amount of energy go down this leg then
what goes down this leg is e 1 minus e
bar oops ok and then that leg with e 1
minus e bar joins up with e 2 so this
line here is e1 plus e2 minus e bar good
and then that sort of has efore leaving
before we go up with the final leg of
the diagram and this final leg therefore
has a 1 plus e 2 minus e 3 minus y bar
good and then the relationship we have
is that this right leg of the box with a
1 plus C 2 minus C 3 minus e bar joins
up oops it's not even it's e 4 look this
is how charmingly informal we're being
that's just that what you have to learn
to live with and then it joins up with a
bar so we get an equation e 1 plus e 2
minus e 4 minus y bar okay that's what's
going up and that like right here right
there joins up with e bar so we say plus
e bar and that combines to make III but
you see what happens two things happen
one is the e bars cancel there's a minus
e bar in a plus e bar and then you just
get II 1 plus e 2 equals e 3 plus e 4 I
move the e 4 from the left to the right
so on the one hand energy is conserved
II 1 plus e to the energy coming in
equals e 3 plus e 4 the energy going out
that's good
but on the other hand the value of a bar
is entirely undetermined by this it can
be anything remember Fineman told us we
have to add up the contributions of
every single Fineman diagram in this
case that means every single fireman
diagram with any value of the energy you
get so in fact the fireman rules say
that the diagram that we drew this way
the diagram as a whole has a
contribution which is given by the sum
over all values of E bar this is the
Greek letter Sigma
meaning summation of all the individual
diagrams with some fixed value of E bar
going that way now really the sum is
over a continuous variable E bar right
so I could write this as the integral of
this little box diagram de bar and
that's the way that you would actually
do it but we're not gonna be that quite
that person icky to hear this write it
as a sum the point is it includes all of
the different values okay well you can
do that song this value ebar remember
you know virtual particles they don't
obey this mass-energy relation right
here that ordinary particles do that
energy can be anything which means it
can be any number from minus infinity to
plus infinity that's allowed for all
these things and you add them up and
what you get is that this diagram equals
an infinitely big contribution that's
the fact of what you get so and the
reason why just to emphasize it is
because e bar itself can go to be
infinitely big so that's the problem
that's the origin of the problem the the
problem with phiman diagrams is that
once you get to loop diagrams which are
gonna be most of the taya Graham's right
they can be very complicated they can
come with a lot of factors of some small
number alpha to some large power but if
you multiply that small number by
infinity
you still get infinity right so these
are the divergences of Feynman diagrams
the divergences of quantum field theory
that have caused problems and it caused
it you know it was a difficult problem
in this word of 1940s 50s this is what
were struggling with I should say that
you know maybe you could take the
attitude that maybe this shouldn't
bother us remember when we did we talked
a little bit about the vacuum energy in
quantum field theory we talked about the
fact that if you have a classical theory
where the zero-point of energy the
lowest point of energy where the field
wasn't doing anything where the kinetic
energy in the gradient energy were all
zero then you did a quantization of that
theory then there's an extra quantum
mechanical contribution every single
mode of the field acts like a harmonic
oscillator every harmonic oscillator has
a zero-point energy over and above the
classical value of 1/2 H bar Omega so
there's an infinitely big energy density
in empty space if you do the naive
quantum field theory prescription in
some but but sorry but the whole point
of it saying that was maybe you
shouldn't have been so naive remember
that's just a calculation not of the
value of the vacuum energy but of the
difference between the classical value
and the quantum value in the real world
there's no such thing as the classical
value the real world just is quantum
mechanical from the start
so the real rule doesn't know that you
chose to start with some classical
contribution and then add to it a
quantum contribution the real world just
knows the answer so in some sense the
same thing is true here in a very real
sense because of these virtual particles
the loop diagrams are intrinsically
quantum mechanical you could do
perturbation theory in classical field
theory and what you would do is only
have tree diagrams that's the way it
works out anytime you have a loop
diagram the contribution is proportional
to H bar Planck's constant to some power
and therefore the loop diagrams are
intrinsically quantum mechanical and the
limit as H bar goes to 0 they go away
so maybe the philosophy you can take is
sure these diagrams are infinitely big
but the thing that is infinite is just
the difference between the classical
prediction of the quantum prediction the
real world is just the quantum
prediction maybe the classical
prediction should be irrelevant and
that's fine that's a perfectly good
attitude to have the problem is how do
you convert this into a useful
calculational scheme right and so this
was the task undertaken by Fineman
but also Schwinger tomonaga
tomonaga and also Freeman Dyson was the
one who showed how it all fit together
and they showed a way to renormalize
quantum electrodynamics from with a
theory what we looked at with this
electrons positrons and photons was
quantum electrodynamics and the way that
they would have put it back when they
were developing this formalism was they
had a way to cancel the infinities
really they would often say somewhat
tongue-in-cheek they were sweeping the
infinities under the rug and really
literally what they would do is say okay
there's an infinite contribution here
let's add some extra Flyman diagram just
by hand which is not integrating over
everything it's just intrinsically there
called a counter term and this counter
term would be equal to minus infinity
and you would add it to the fireman
diagram expansion and subtract it off
and by saying it that way it sounds
completely hokey it sounds completely
impossible infinity minus infinity can
get you a finite number
but infinity minus infinity can get you
any number you want that's not just what
these folks did what they did was give
you a very specific rigorous
mathematical procedure for taking the
limit of both the regular Feynman
diagrams and the counter terms in such a
way that you get a fixed finite answer
and the answer is amazingly successful
QED is the most rigorously precisely
tested physical theory of all time I
forget how many decimal places it is now
but something like twelve thirteen
decimal places of accuracy the
predictions of the theory and the
experimental results work out to be in
agreement so on the one hand it was
successful as a theory it works you can
fit the data
that's good that's what you want to do
on the other hand it was a little bit
intuitively unsatisfying you know it
felt like there was something deep and
important going on that was just being
hidden rather than being confronted
straightforwardly so this was figured
out really to most physicists
satisfaction in the 1970s by Ken Wilson
who was a less famous person than
Fineman were
swinger etc but what he did was really
set the stage for all the triumphs of
quantum field theory in the 1970s and
beyond so this is in the 1970s and what
he did can be summed up in the phrase he
invented effective field theory an
effective field theory is sort of a
philosophy in some way but it's also a
very rigorous set of rules that you can
use the basic idea behind effective
field theory is its analogous in some
ways remember when Hugh Everett said you
have all these branches of the
wavefunction and you know what that's
okay you can just deal with them they
can just be there it doesn't really
bother you what Ken Wilson says is when
you do these fireman diagrams the reason
you get infinities is because you're
including contributions from arbitrarily
high energies and remember energy is
basically equal to 1 over the wavelength
of the mode you're looking at okay there
might be two pies in there etc but
that's the basic idea and so high
energies means short distances that's
where your infinity is coming from but
high energies and short distances is
exactly where Wilson says we don't know
what we're doing right we don't know
whether what quantum field theory is
actually telling us at those short
distances if we know some things like ok
we have electrons let's say you have
electrons and photons and you're doing
QED right you should be able to do that
to do QED without knowing about the
existence of protons and neutrons those
are much heavier particles if you just
have slowly moving electrons you
shouldn't be bothered by the existence
of protons and things like that
ok Fineman diagrams that include protons
in them shouldn't be relevant to you
likewise if you think that space-time
itself breaks down at the Planck scale
at the Planck length very very short
distances maybe it does but you've
included in your climate diagram
infinity distance is much much shorter
than the Planck scale so why should that
bother you when you know that those
might not even be there so Wilson's
philosophy is admit that we don't
understand things are very high energies
and the way that he quantifies that
physics let's say at energies he says
let's you tell me the energy scale up to
which you think you do understand
physics and I will put a cutoff at that
energies greater than some cutoff energy
e star so this is called the cutoff okay
and what he says is we admit that but
it's not just we admit it we put that
into our equations explicitly and see
what happens and the goal is to use this
fact that what matters to us are the
physical predictions not the way that we
got them so if we can make a scheme for
inventing physical predictions that
doesn't depend on what happens at
energies above the cutoff then that's
what we should use and that's exactly
what we're able to do so in pictures
what you should imagine is here's energy
and Wilson says we can divide all the
modes right we have all these
wavelengths and the wavelengths are
related to energy they're inversely
proportional so we have some cutoff east
star and we label everything at energies
above East our high energy and the
ultraviolet as it is called and this is
regimes where the wavelengths are short
okay so these are short wavelengths and
down here below the cutoff
we have long wavelengths and this is the
labels we put on here this is the UV
okay and this is the IR and this is
literally standing for ultraviolet and
infrared ultraviolet short wavelength
infrared long wavelength okay we say
look the ultraviolet is unknown to us we
don't know what's going on there the
infrared is what we care about that's
what we're trying to invent a theory to
describe now you might say well I would
like to invent a theory that describes
everything in the universe that goes up
to all wavelengths you know bully for
you that is an awesome thing to try to
do that's what string theory is try to
do
for example so in that case you would
not be doing an effective field theory
you'd be doing a full theory of
everything but most of the time when we
do the standard model of particle
physics or QED we do atoms and the Higgs
boson and stuff like that we're not
pretending to describe everything in the
universe we're tending we're pretending
to describe we are describing things
below a certain energy below a certain
cutoff and then Wilson says it's okay to
ignore what happens in the ultraviolet
in fact it can be the case that a single
infrared Theory has more than one or
zero for that matter
ultraviolet completions as we call them
so given the theory that we know below
the cutoff there may be many different
versions of the theory above the cutoff
that give us the same predictions in the
infrared so why are we sweating
ourselves worrying about what's going on
in the ultraviolet just to give you some
numbers here you know we always set C
equals to 1 when we do particle physics
C equals 1 so we and E the rest mass we
know is MC squared so if C equals 1 then
e equals M and we often use energy and
mass interchangeably so just to give you
an idea of what we mean when we say cut
off you know the mass of the photon is
zero the mass of the electron you know
that right the photon is massless the
mass of the electron is typical in
particle physics to describe masses of
particles in energy units rather than in
mass units because we always set C
equals 1 and the unit we typically use
is the electron bolt I don't know why we
use the electron bolt to be perfectly
honest the electron volt is amount of
energy it takes to take one electron and
move it through an electrical potential
of 1 volt that's how it's defined and it
turns out the mass of the electron can
be written as 0.5 1 1 million electron
volts MeV equals 10 to the sixth
electron volts whereas the mass of the
proton is I think 938 if I'm remembering
correct
meb so roughly 1 GeV 1 billion electron
volts so 1800 times bigger is the mass
of the proton and the mass of the
electron and the Planck mass right this
energy scale that is purportedly
characteristic of quantum gravity is
roughly 10 to the what is it 27 electron
volts so the Senate of eighteen I pick
MeV which is dumb because I usually
think in terms of GeV so let me just
write now let's stick with it 10 to the
21 MeV
okay the point is the Planck scale these
ultra high-energy scales they are way
bigger than the energy scales of
particle physics or of let's say
chemistry right if you say chemistry e
chemistry what do I mean by that well if
you have different chemical reactions
going on in your body or in a test tube
or something like that what's really
going on is the electrons and the
orbitals around the atom are hopping
into different energy levels or
combining and so forth so there is a
characteristic scale which is maybe
between 1 and 10 electron volts that is
the reason why electron volts are
convenient units so all of these are way
smaller than the masses of the particles
that we're talking about anyway the
point is there are these large large
hierarchies in the energy scales of
particle physics so it is very plausible
at least that you can imagine doing
physics at a low energy scale while
ignoring energies at a high energy scale
that's the philosophy of effective field
theory to be fair you might have a
little bit of anxiety about this because
you might say there's various kinds of
anxiety we'll talk about them as we go
along the way here is one you say look
if I have a physical system made of
multiple moving parts right let's say
you know I have a lot of Springs that
are tied to each other in different ways
generally speaking I cannot just say
well I'm going to ignore some of the
springs I'm going to keep some of the
other ones I would not get a sensible
closed internally consistent theory that
way so Wilson is not just saying oh
let's ignore things we don't understand
he's saying that we can consistently
ignore these things we don't understand
and still get a consistent theory for
the things that we're keeping track of
and roughly speaking the reason why is
because these ultraviolet degrees of
freedom are not doing anything
dynamically okay they might appear in
the inside of quantum field theory
calculations of Fineman diagrams but
that's sort of a passive role as long as
none of these ultraviolet
degrees-of-freedom particles or new
forces or whatever are part of the
ingoing particles or outgoing particles
whatever their effect is it just gets
mushed together in one big effect that
is literally renormalization it gets
renormalized into one big effect let me
show you what that is in action okay to
put this into action what I'm gonna try
to argue is that this idea of ignoring
ultraviolet degrees of freedom and
focusing on infrared ones
not only sounds good because it gets rid
of infinities oh yeah I didn't actually
say this let me uh let me finish let me
finish the whole point of this here the
point is in the effective field theory
okay and what Wilson says ignore the
ultraviolet theories what that means
what that amounts to is treat this kind
of diagram as the sum over energies that
are less than or equal to the cut off so
E bar is less than or equal to e star
the cut off of this diagram there's a
specific value of energy E bar going
around and that will turn out to be
finite that's the scheme that is the
effective field Theory approach you can
make all of your calculations finite by
imposing an explicit cutoff and there
are a few reasons you might want to
worry about that so one is that it just
doesn't give you consistent theory but
I'll argue that it does the other is
that Y bar sorry e star the cutoff okay
seems arbitrary I will talk about that
later meanwhile let me just tell you why
this works because it works very
effectively as it were
and the reason why it works comes down
to dimensional analysis now once again I
have to apologize because the word
dimension is used you can get again a
different sense than it's been used
before we talk about dimensions of space
up down left right forward backward and
I went to the pains to emphasize that
that's a different notion of dimension
than the simple abstract mathematical
notion of the dimension of an arbitrary
set in the mathematical sense so Hilbert
space the set of all possible wave
functions is really big it might be
infinitely big it might be just super
big but not infinite but it has a large
number of dimensions and those
dimensions are the number of independent
vectors that you could add together the
number of perpendicular vectors you
could construct in Hilbert space ok
those are not dimensions in the sense of
a place you could go or a direction you
could move in they're different than the
dimensions of space this use of the word
dimension is yet again a different
notion of dimension this is basically
units ok if you took a introductory
physics class in college it's very
possible very likely that the first
lecture or two were on units in physics
and dimensional analysis so we attach
units to different physical quantities
right we talk about mass energy distance
time stuff like that in fact the number
of units is very large pressure has
units electrical resistivity has units
all these things but in but but the key
thing is if you add two quantities
together they better have the same units
you cannot add a certain number of fluid
ounces to a certain number of years that
makes no sense you can multiply them
together but if you're adding different
terms in an equation all of them better
have the same units a nice feature is
that you only need for almost all
purposes you only need three basic units
because you can combine different units
together to form the set of anything you
want for example energy E we know that
there is a formula e equals mc-squared
right so this is a formula it says the
energy of an object at rest comes with a
certain amount of intrinsic energy
is its mass times the speed of light
squared and so if the units of both
sides of this equation you're going to
add up are going to be consistent we
better have the units of energy which
I'm going to write E in square brackets
better be equal to the units of mass
times the units of velocity squared
velocity is distance divided by time so
this is mass times distance squared
divided by time squared so all you need
to express energy is our units of mass
de mis Tain's and time in whatever
series you want
so CGS is a common choice centimeters
grams and seconds MKS meters kilograms
and seconds is another common choice but
lengths mass and time that's what you
need to be able to measure now particle
physicists go even further they say
they're gonna set not only C equals 1
but also H bar equals 1 okay and the
dimensions of C are of course it's a
velocity so it's distance delighted by
time so when you set C equals 1 when you
use units in which the speed of light
equals 1 that automatically means that
the units of distance are the same as
the units of time we can always convert
distances into times and vice versa by
multiplying by one by multiplying the
appropriate factor of C okay so you see
that by setting certain things equal to
one different units become compatible
because we've hidden a conversion factor
in this case the speed of light likewise
we have h-bar its units I don't know
this unit sorry but I wrote them down
here mass times distance squared divided
by time so now if distance and time were
the same an H bar also equals 1 we can
convert either distance or time into
mass and of course mass has the same
units of energy and so forth so we
actually simplify our lives a great deal
these are called natural units like
particle physicists anyway and as I said
I think you know videos ago they're so
ingrained in my head I don't even
remember where the C's go and where the
bars go but you can always work them out
by dimensional analysis there's another
set of Units which is called plunk units
where you set C equals one H bar equals
1 and also Newton's constant of gravity
equals to 1 and then all the units
disappear I think that's going too far
to be honest because keeping some units
around is actually good for your soul
and also good for checking your
equations that you have not made
mistakes
so we're not going to use plunk units
we're not going to set the speed we're
not going to set plot Newton's constant
equal to 1 so the plunk mass the plunk
energy these are all dimensional
quantities we will keep around but we
will use C equals 1 and H bar equals 1
and so in those units given that all
these things are true okay then it turns
out we can pick one unit and just use
that for everything one unit to some
power and we're gonna pick energy
because that's what particle physicists
typically pick like I already told you
the mass of the electron and units of
energy so that's the kind of thing that
will do so in these units what you find
is that energy and mass have the same
units you knew that already from C
equals 1 but also distance has units of
1 over energy you can work that out and
time well time has the same units of
distance since C equals 1 so time also
has the units of 1 over energy leaving a
little bit of steps here for you to do
at home because you know it's kind of
like you gotta learn these things it's
fun to play around and do dimensional
analysis look let me tell you the next
few minutes of the video we're gonna
like be kind of persnickety we're gonna
be kind of careful and go through this
and it might seem like why are we
suddenly doing all this work rather than
just leaping to the answer like we
usually do it will pay off ok we're
gonna do a little bit of dimensional
analysis it will actually pay off in a
really interesting way so stick with me
why are we doing this why are we why are
we doing this dimensional analysis stuff
well we're doing field theory right and
for simplicity we're doing scalar field
theory and we want to be able to think
about the equations of motion for our
scalar field using dimensional analysis
we'll help
understand what kinds of equations of
motion we should expect that's a
remarkable fact I mean dimensional
analysis is almost trivial right I mean
there's no substance in there there's no
statement that we've made about the
nature of reality by doing dimensional
analysis it's just a requirement of
mathematical consistency but by doing it
correctly we will actually learn
something or at least it will suggest
something about the structure of the
equations that govern physical reality
that's an impressive feat so in this
scalar field theory what would the first
question we ask what are the dimensions
of Phi right what are the dimensions of
our field itself our field will appear
in the equations of motion for itself so
we would like to know what units it has
what dimensions and we can't just guess
you know you don't invent a field theory
you do a minute field theory that's what
physicists do all the time they invent
field theories but you don't say I'm
gonna invent a theory of a field with
the following units the units have to
come out consistently from the equations
that the field obeys so what do you do
is you write down a field theory you
find it's equations and from that you
derive what the dimensions of Phi have
to be so for example the example we'll
use here is something that I'm just
going to assert is true is that I know
what the kinetic energy of the scalar
field is it's one-half times the Phi dot
squared Phi dot is the time derivative D
Phi DT and really if I'm honest with you
it's not the kinetic energy is the
kinetic energy density so the kinetic
energy density reason why it's a density
reflects the fact that in a field theory
the field exists at every point in space
right everywhere in space there's a
value of the field it might be changing
up and down and so at every point in
space there's a little bit of kinetic
energy to get the amount of kinetic
energy in a region you integrate over
that entire region right every little
point contributes to it you add those up
to get the kinetic energy so the formula
you originally proposed is for the
density for the kinetic energy at any
one point the quantity you would
integrate up to get the whole kinetic
energy and so that has units of kinetic
energy
oops
per spatial volume right
it's a certain amount of energy in this
spatial region and the units of that oh
sorry
the the equation for that is that it is
one-half the derivative of Phi with
respect to time squared okay so I'm like
T's look a little bit like epsilon so
that would be miss dink
so at every point the field is moving up
and down it has a time derivative it
might be zero but it has a value of the
time derivative and that value squared
is the kinetic energy that I use squared
times one-half is the kinetic energy and
this I'm just telling you this I'm not
driving it not justifying it but it
shouldn't be that weird or unusual
looking for a particle the kinetic
energy is one-half MV squared and I
think of M is a constant associated with
the particle the kinetic energy goes
like the velocity squared the rate of
change of position squared so the fact
that the kinetic energy of the scalar
field goes as the rate of change of the
field squared should come as no surprise
so let's do some dimensional analysis to
this equation kinetic energy density
kinetic energy per spatial volume the
units of that are energy per spatial
volume which is distance cubed right a
little tiny volume three-dimensional
distance cubed or assuming space
three-dimensional for the purposes of
this lecture and we said that distance
itself has units of 1 over energy so
energy over distance cube has units of
energy to the fourth good and 1/2 D Phi
DT squared rate of change of Phi with
respect to time that has units well
whatever
well one half is no units at all what
happens at natural dimensionless number
okay it's the same in any units it
wouldn't change if you went from
centimeters to inches 1/2 as 1/2 Phi has
units so I don't know what those units
are but whatever the units of Phi are D
Phi DT squared hat comes with units of
Phi squared divided by units of time
squared so the DS don't matter this is
saying there's a certain change in Phi
per change in time so the units of
whatever that change is is 5/2
and we've squared it and we know the
time has units of 1 over energy we set
that right up here so this has units of
5 squared times energy squared and the
unit's here better be the same so we
have energy to the fourth is the same as
the units of five times energy squared
so that works out if and only if the
units of Phi are energy there you go we
calculated something in quantum field
theory in some very ill-defined sense
very loosely defined sense not bill
defying sense okay the units of our
field itself are that of energy now by
the way that's true for this particular
scalar field for other theories the
units will be different it turns out
that in QED for example we have the
electron the positron the photon
electrons and positrons have units of
energy to the three-halves power and the
photons have units of energy just like
the scalar field does so you have to
keep your wits about you you have to do
this separately for every kind of field
that you're looking at okay now that was
a little tedious we had to do it it's
about to all come together in an
interesting piece of physics so remember
we had the action right when we defined
our theories we have an action and we're
gonna minimize the action classically
quantum mechanically we will can do a
path integral over all the possible
paths and add up different contributions
depending on what their actions are none
of that is relevant right now what
matters is the equations of motion for
our field will be derived from an action
so the action we know is the integral of
the Lagrangian over time good and we
know that the Lagrangian s'ti sets are
the Lagrangian L equals an integral over
lagrangian s'ti d3x
so this is the Lagrangian satine
and d3x of course is a little volume of
space an infinitesimally tiny volume of
space dxdydz
so the point of this I think I've
mentioned this before but the point of
this is in field theory we're gonna
define our fields our our equations of
motion for our fields by specifying the
lagrangian s'ti that is the quantity of
interest this is what particle
physicists field theorists spend all
their time doing is writing down the
grunge densities so much so that they
will often forget the word density and
even though the actual Lagrangian is the
integral of the grunge density over all
space they will refer to this quantity
script L as the Lagrangian so sometimes
I will slip and do that as well
none of that is really important but I'm
focusing in on the Lagrangian city
because it is the thing out of which we
will make our field theory so you want
to do our dimensional analysis on it
well what do we know the dimensions of
the Lagrangian you know what those are
because the dimensions of Lagrangian the
Lagrangian itself for point particles
was kinetic energy minus potential
energy for field theory it's the same
kind of thing at least it's there's
extra terms in there for grading to
energy and interaction energy but it
still has the same units so the energy
so the unit of Lagrangian is just the
units of energy that's what the
definition of a Lagrangian is okay and
the units of d3x well that's a little
volume of space so it has units of size
distance cubed which is one over energy
cubed okay so capital L Roman L has
units of energy D 3xs units of energy to
the minus three we can therefore infer
that script Alva LeGrande density better
have units of energy to the fourth this
is what the l'orange density needs to
have four units to make everything work
out then energy the fourth times energy
the minus three equals energy that all
makes sense why why do we care about
this well remember professor Fineman
taught us that there is a way of
going from terms in the Lagrangian s'ti
to find Minh diagrams or in particular
to the fundamental vertices the basic
interactions out of which we construct
more elaborate Fineman diagrams and
roughly speaking very roughly speaking
sorry about that it goes like this if
you have a term it looks like phi q --b
in the lagrangian s'ti then you will get
a fundamental vertex and interaction
with three factors of Phi
there's a Phi Phi Phi that's what a
fight cubed interaction does in the
Lagrangian s'ti it corresponds to a
Fineman diagram with three fives and
remember it doesn't matter whether one
goes in and to come out or to go in and
want to go out we can move the lines as
long as we keep track of particles
versus anti particles if you have five
four in what I mean by this is the
Lagrangian density is a sum of different
terms right kinetic energy potential
energy interaction energies so when I
say Phi cubed in L I mean when there is
a term in that sum that is of the form
Phi cubed times some numbers okay time
some coupling constants well then you
can guess what you're gonna get you're
gonna get a four point vertex as it's
called for five particles interacting
with each other five to the fifth in the
LeGrande enca T implies that there is a
vertex where five five particles are
interacting and so forth okay now wait a
minute
this is telling us something because
remember that the dimensions of Phi are
the dimensions of energy and we want the
Lagrangian s'ti to have dimensions of
energy to the fourth so you might guess
and you'll be incorrect but you might
guess that you could only have five to
the fourth in your the Raj density
because Phi to the fourth automatically
has the right units the right dimensions
to be in the Lagrangian s'ti its energy
to the fourth Phi is energy and fly to
the fourth is energy to the fourth
that's what we want for our Lagrange
density but what we're neglecting in
that is that each one of these
possibilities also comes with a coupling
constant and so the solution to have any
one of these or more right etc is to
have the coupling constants themselves
have the appropriate units so what we do
is we write L and I'm not gonna write
out the whole thing the Lagrangian
sitting for typical quantum field theory
has a bunch of terms we don't need to
care about them we're just illustrating
some features of the general principle
so let's just write that there is some
coefficient C 3 times 5 cubed plus C 4
times 5 to the 4th plus C 5 times Phi to
the fifth plus etc and you might say
well okay first off I don't want to have
all those terms like what if I have a
simple theory what if my theories just
so elegant only takes two terms to write
down well again good for you but we're
doing effective field theory ok so even
if you only had is it I digress and I'm
gonna race it let's imagine you only had
5 C 3 Phi cubed in your field theory
that would lead to a Fineman diagram
that is just this little vertex
ok Phi Phi Phi but then I could
construct from that the following
diagram with four lines in it okay and
so that contributes to this blob where
four particles are coming out I could
also construct a Flyman diagram that
looks like this where this contributes
to a process where two particles go in
and three go out as if there was a
fundamental Phi to the fourth vertex and
Phi QB vertex and because the philosophy
of effective field theory is that I
neglect things at very very high
energies I can't tell at low energies
whether my Phi to the fourth interaction
or fight of the fifth interaction was
fundamental or whether it just came from
integrating out from including all the
high energy processes that I'm
neglecting above the cutoff so for the
effective field theorist you don't have
a choice when you start writing down
terms in your Lagrangian you have to
include them all as long as they don't
violate some symmetry or something like
that every term that you're allowed to
write down you have to write down
because you're sort of hiding a whole
bunch of effects and therefore you have
a mess at the end of the day now that
doesn't sound like progress right that
sounds bad by neglecting things at high
energies we forced ourselves to include
a whole bunch of terms in our effective
lagrangian why is that supposed to be
good well because of this fact that we
want the Lagrangian LaGrant density to
have units of energy to the fourth we
know that these different coupling
constants need to have different units
the dimensions of C cubed better be the
dimensions of energy the dimensions of C
to the fourth
well it's dimensionless we just write
one this is a true number when we did
the fine-structure constant that's just
a number the fine-structure constant
doesn't have dimensions 1 over 137 it's
just the number and that was okay
because it was multiplying in the
interaction lagrangian electron-positron
photon electron has units of energy 3/4
sorry energy of three-halves well let me
let me do this carefully I can slow down
we're not in a hurry right for QED we
had an interaction LeGrande you looked
like square root of alpha e minus E Plus
gamma electron positron Photon it turns
out that the units of the electron are
energy to the three-halves units of the
positron better be the same because
they're anti particles right energy to
the three-halves units of photon or
energy to the power 1 and therefore the
Lagrangian City naturally has units of
energy to the 4th
even though alpha is dimensionless so
that that's nice it's a nice little
LaGrant density for QED good for us
but now we're doing this scalar field
theory it's constructing it from scratch
and so the coefficient of Phi to the
fourth like alpha is just a general
natural number it has no dimensions but
C 5 as units and the units are 1 over
energy
and etc see to the sixth will be one
over energy squared C to the seventh
will be one over energy to the third etc
okay so you can see the pattern as you
get to larger and larger powers of Phi
in your interaction Lagrangian you get
coupling constants that are larger and
larger negative powers of the energy
that's just a fact is very natural it's
gonna make dimensional analysis work out
why do we care
well because there is a natural
expectation and here's where we begin to
sort of wave our hands a little bit but
it's a good way of hand waving the
natural expectation is the following
whatever the coupling constants of your
theory are these coupling constants are
of an effective field theory right we
have a cut-off east arm so there's a
bunch of things going up at above energy
energies above East are okay so they all
contribute to these effective parameters
that we will measure C 3 C 4 C 5 and
therefore with we know of the dimensions
of C 3 C 4 C 5 alarm we have a natural
expectation for what their values are
going to be namely the appropriate
powers of e star of the cutoff we would
guess if we didn't know any better if
there was any fine tuning or secretly
tweaking the numbers behind the scenes
we would guess that C 3 would be of
order this curly o means roughly of the
order of the value of the cutoff East
are I mean maybe it's 10 times bigger or
10 times smaller or even 100 or whatever
but it's not like if it were ten to the
twenty times bigger that'll be weird
that would just make no sense to us we
would suspect something was going on C
for dimensionless really expected to be
of order one remember alpha which was
the one over hundred thirty-seven so the
parameter that appeared in the
Lagrangian said he was a square root of
alpha so that is in fact you know aboard
a one very roughly it's not like 10 to
the -20 C to the five we would expect to
be of order 1 over e star
etc as you go to higher and higher
powers more and more East soars in the
denominator and remember we are working
at energies well below the cutoff that's
the point we're trying to construct a
theory of processes and particles with
energies well below our energy cut off
in the Wilsonian sense and therefore
when you get to things like this they
shouldn't matter processes that have
coupling constants that are order one
over the cutoff should be technically
speaking irrelevant
so in fact we invent some nomenclature
some some language for this we say there
can be you know we didn't write it down
yet but there can be terminal agrandi in
situ v squared right we didn't write it
down because it's not an interaction
it's part of the mass of the particle
the field squared is part of the free
field theory that defines the mass of
the particle it's not an interaction
with anything else but we can put it in
situ v squared C 3 Phi cubed these are
called relevant interactions whereas C 4
v to the fourth is called a marginal
interaction and C 5 5 - 5 C 6 Y to the
sixth etc are called irrelevant
interactions well I mean is in the limit
as the cutoff gets very very big the
physical processes that are governed by
the irrelevant interactions literally
become irrelevant
they do become less and less likely
remember when we're talking about
chemistry energies right 10 electron
volts and if you put a cutoff even at
the Higgs max okay
the Higgs mass remember the Higgs mass
was of order 10 to the 2 GeV billion
electron volts sometimes we talk about
the electroweak scale as sort of just a
catch-all term for things that happen in
this electroweak theory the electroweak
theory was this
theory from steven weinberg in the 1960s
he unified electromagnetism and the weak
nuclear force by putting in a Higgs
boson this is 1967 and then decades
later in 2012 we discovered the Higgs
boson so we might say that roughly
speaking this is like 10 to the 3 okay
so that that rough energy scale a
hundred or a thousand billion electron
volts is where modern particle
accelerators have gotten up to okay
that's the Large Hadron Collider energy
roughly speaking the highest possible
thing you can get at the Large Hadron
Collider is a board or 10 to the 4 GV or
something like that but the point is all
of these energies are well above what
you do with electrons and protons in
everyday interactions so if you neglect
if you have a cut-off as let's say 10 to
the 3 GeV okay if you're doing an
experiment at 10 electron volts and your
cutoff east R is 10 to the 3 GB a
jeebies 10 to the 9 electron volts so
that's 10 to the 12 electron volts then
you can neglect terms in your equations
of motion that are order 10 divided by
10 to the 12 to some power n okay that's
10 to minus 11 times some power n so all
these irrelevant operators are exactly
that there are contributions from your
equations of motion but they are
suppressed by a big number 10 to the
minus 11 outside them or 10 to minus 22
or 1000 minus 33 or whatever so that's
why these aren't irrelevant operators
now in the old days old days before
Wilson came along we spent a lot of
worry worrying about what are called
renormalizable theories in other words
theories that in principle make sense
all the way up to infinite energy by
this trick that Fineman and his friends
figured out by subtracting off the
infinities so normalizable theories are
that only have relevant and marginal
operators
I shouldn't say operators operators is
the technical term that's what people
say but let me say interactions that's
why I said before okay so here we go
oops yeah five squared Phi cubed Y to
the fourth are either marginal or
irrelevant Phi to the fifth Y to the
sixth are irrelevant operators and the
point is that the trick that Fineman and
schwinger and tominaga and dyson the
trick set of tricks they figured out
work only if you start with just
relevant operators and marginal
operators so if you started in your
theory with irrelevant operators then
you wouldn't know what happens if he
tries to do physics at very high energy
scales then these operators that were
irrelevant at low energies would become
super relevant at high energies okay and
so you couldn't sweep the infinities
under the rug the infinities would
really really matter if these irrelevant
operators were part and parcel of your
fundamental description of the theory if
they're just in your effective theory
with a cut-off that's okay that doesn't
matter but if they're in your
fundamental theory that would bother you
so in the 1560s even into the 70s people
thought that their job was to find
theories that would work up to
arbitrarily high energies so it was a
big discovery by gerardo toughed in the
early 1970s that Weinberg's electroweak
theory was renormalizable that you could
write it in a form where all of the
interactions had this nice marginal or
relevant form sadly Einstein's theory of
general relativity try to quantize it as
a quantum field theory is not a
renormalizable
theory but that doesn't mean you can't
do quantum gravity it just means you
can't extend quantum gravity up to
arbitrarily high energies Einstein's
general relativity has a quantum version
as an effective field theory that works
perfectly well if you want to figure out
the scattering of two gravitons at low
energy we can do that no problem
we just can't extend what we're doing up
to arbitrarily high energies it's not a
renormalizable theory in that
and these days since we know that
getting the theory of everything is
going to be hard it doesn't bother us so
much if we write down a non-normalizable
theory we only expect it to work up to a
certain cutoff until unless you're
actually trying to do string theory or
the theory of everything or whatever so
those are the old days these days new
new days we're happy with effective
field theories and the effective field
theories have all the terms of all the
interactions but the higher-order ones
the irrelevant ones are just very
irrelevant they're just small okay
so now the payoff comes yeah this was
not yet to pay off I tried to explain
why we did this dimensional analysis to
figure out that different interactions
would naturally be relevant or
irrelevant but the payoff is that there
aren't that many relevant interactions
okay there's only a small number of
relevant or marginal interactions you
can write down so what that means is
because basically I mean that it should
be clear why that's true because
marginal or relevant interactions have a
small number of fields appearing in them
once you add more and more fields to
make things more complicated chances are
you're making your interaction less and
less relevant irrelevant something that
drops out at high energies so that's why
effective field theories are so powerful
because even though we're admitting that
we don't know what happens at super high
energies if you just tell me the fields
that you have in the symmetries of the
open they obey I can figure out what the
effective field theory will be at low
energies really simply and it comes with
a small number of parameters that I can
then go measure and I can use it okay so
you don't need to know arbitrarily
complicated things to do effective field
theory that is an extraordinarily
powerful idea you can you know you can
try to like go up to the cutoff and
learn new things there's a whole field
of endeavor called electroweak precision
measurements which says the following
thing you know if you have interactions
oops if you have loop diagrams okay
which you know loops are important and
there's some energy floating around them
and you can look at energies for your
ingoing and outgoing particles that are
near the cutoff then there's always a
lot more experimental numbers you can
measure then there are parameters in
your effective field theory ok the
parameters in your effective field
theory c1 c2 etc the relevant and
marginal operators it's a small number
of them that's the payoff but there's a
large number of things you could measure
you measure decay rates and scattering
amplitudes of different particles at
different energies and so forth so
they're incredibly over constrained what
this means is the good news bad news
situation the good news is you can in
principle discover new physics without
discovering new particles you can find a
breakdown of effective field theory with
a cut-off you can you can find out that
the prediction you make just on the
basis of your particles in your
effective field theory doesn't match
with your experimental data and what you
would conclude is that your cutoff
has gone up to the place where new
physics is kicking in where there's some
particles or forces which you didn't
know about which maybe you're seeing the
hints of even though they're only
virtual particles you can figure out
that they're there that's the good news
that the effective field theory can let
you discover new physics even without
directly seeing the particles the bad
news is that if your new physics is very
very energetic is up there at mass
scales or energy scales that are very
very high then you will never see it
then there is no experiment you can do
that we'll show it to you because you
just don't have the precision to reach
those effects at those very very high
energies this is why it is essentially
impossible to test string theory at the
Large Hadron Collider right the energy
scale for string theory is roughly the
the Planck scale so that's 10 to the 18
GeV and the energy scale for Large
Hadron Collider is roughly 10 to the 3
GeV maybe 10 to the 4 let's give it the
Large Hadron Collider a little bit
benefit of the down here
but the point is still 14 orders of
magnitude away and so every string
theory effect that you might want to see
is suppressed by 10 to the 4 over 10 to
the 18 to some power which is a tiny
tiny number you might get lucky you know
as we said before that you have a
scaling with energy of a certain kind
but then there's a constant of
proportionality outside maybe there's a
stringing effect which even though it's
suppressed by this large energy factor
is still Jai humongous by its own right
and therefore it has a tiny little
effect even at Large Hadron Collider
energies that's why it's important to
try to look but you shouldn't be
surprised if at the end of the day you
do all the experiments you can and you
see no effects of Planck scale physics
at the Large Hadron Collider or anywhere
else so that's the good news and bad
news good news is you can do all this
physics without knowing the ultraviolet
bad news is you can do all this physics
without knowing the ultraviolet without
learning anything about what's going on
in the ultraviolet without learning
anything about what's going on at very
very small scales ok two more little
facts I want to give you one is not
really fact it's I want to sort of a
swage a worry that you probably had from
the start you know there's a worry with
all this effective field theory stuff
isn't the cutoff B star isn't the energy
cutoff arbitrary after all right I mean
if I think well I understand physics up
to 2000 DV but you think you understand
physics up to 3000 GeV then wouldn't we
use different values of the cutoff in
our calculations and so are we including
different Fineman diagrams right my
Fineman diagrams are integrated up to
2,000 GeV yours are integrated up to
3,000 GeV wouldn't that give us
different answers right well no so this
is again the beauty of effective field
theory is that the way that Wilson sets
it up you use the cutoff this is your
cutoff energy cutoff you use the cutoff
to do your calculations but none of the
calculations at the end of the day
depend on the cutoff the parameters what
you would call the coupling constants
depend on the
but the physical answer for the
probability that certain particles
scatter or decay or whatever never
depends on the cutoff and this is called
the renormalization group and it's a
terrible name because it's not a group
in the group Theory sense at all but
this is the fact that coupling constants
I'm gonna put constants in quotes here
scare quotes ah coupling constants
evolve with changing cutoff or changing
energy so we do is we say that you know
you have some what is the best way to
say this when I write my Lagrangian my
interaction Lagrangian it includes
things like c35 cubed but that's C 3 the
specific numerical value will depend on
the value that I choose for the cutoff
and then likewise C 4 etc and there's
some very specific functional form for
exactly that dependence and we can
calculate what that functional form is
so if you change your cutoff you're
basically saying that I'm including
different kinds of energies than you are
and my coupling constants in my
effective field theory shift to
compensate so that the probability of
any physical process remains the same
that's the renormalization group flow as
it's called the flow of the coupling
constants alright and that's not just a
mathematical trick okay it's a real why
can't I write the word flow what's wrong
with this look it's late in the day
folks where I'm doing this okay there
you go it's not just a mathematical
trick it reflects a real physical
phenomenon and so let me give you a
cartoonish version of what this physical
phenomenon is something you may have
seen before
but let me give it to you and your more
sophisticated now than you were a few
lectures ago right a few videos ago
here's an electron
electron as we know is not a fundamental
particle it is a vibration and
excitation mode in a quantum field the
electron field and also as we know there
are these other fields right positrons
photons and so forth that interact with
the electron field and we can think
about them
courtesy of Richard Feynman in terms of
virtual particles popping in and out of
existence okay and that's true not just
when the particle is interacting and
Fineman diagram it's true and the
particles just sitting there you can
think of this in this five in diagram
language which remember is just a story
that we tell each other that helps us do
calculations and get some intuition the
reality is there's an electron and their
fields around it that adjust to be in
their minimum energy consider a
configuration given that there is an
electron there okay but the Fineman
diagram language is that there are
virtual particles popping in and out of
existence that makes you seem to get the
impression that something dynamical is
happening and if you look at the
electron over time it will be changing
but it's not it's an electron okay
nevertheless it's very helpful to use
this this fun phiman diagram language so
we'll do that so we can think of this
electron as being surrounded by a cloud
of let's say this is a positron and this
is an ellipse positron here let me show
my technological abilities here by
changing the width of my pen did that so
here's an A plus e minus and we can
imagine that our electron is surrounded
by this cloud of virtual particle anti
particle pairs popping in and out of
existence okay all the time this is the
story that we're telling each other even
though it's not completely accurate but
still these electrons you know it's you
have to be careful to sort of conserve
energy so if the energy of one is
positive the energy that is negative etc
these virtual particles can interact
with the electron within physical real
electron just like other things do so
there are photons that are exchanged
between these and guess what
and a negatively charged electron will
attract positive
ron's which have a positive charge it
will repel other electrons so there is
an overall tendency for the positrons to
be close to the electron positron sort
of align themselves up on the side
closer to the electron whereas the
electrons the virtual electrons end up
being pushed a little bit away from the
real electron and this is a real
physical effect this is called vacuum
polarization polarization in the sense
that there's a directionality to what is
going on and this physical effect has
experimental consequences you make my
pen big again
the experimental consequences are the
following we probe the electron using
other quantum fields that's the only way
we have of probing it so when I say
probe it I say you know we scatter a
particle off it to measure the
fine-structure constant for example the
fine-structure constant is an
encapsulation of the electric charge of
the electron the define structure
constant is a way of saying how powerful
is the fundamental unit of electric
charge but when we measure the charge of
the electron we do it with some other
quantum field which itself has a
wavelength right because they're all
waves and if it's a low-energy quantum
field then the wavelength is going to be
larger and that's like using a lower
resolution probe a large wavelength
field doesn't probe as deeply close to
the real electron as a high frequency
high-energy probe would so let's imagine
that we have a low energy probe maybe
what it can see around the electron is a
region like this big okay I'm going to
draw a dashed circle to indicate what is
actually being observed by some
low-energy probe as opposed to a higher
energy probe gets to sort of sneak
inside and look closer to the electron
because it is it has a smaller
wavelength so this might be the
resolution scale of a higher energy
probe
and what you see is when you ask using
these different probes what is the
charge of the electron the high-energy
probe in this very simple cartoon that
we've drawn sees more or less the
fundamental electron by itself the
low-energy probe sees the electron but
also it's a fact the effect that it
measures is also affected by these
virtual particles and the virtual
particles are predominantly positrons
not electrons it's not a five to one
ratio like it looks like from this
picture because the electron positron
virtual particles are popping it out of
existence very very quickly in this
story but there is a tiny shift in the
effective charge of the electron because
the charge of the low-energy probe sees
is a combination of the charge of the
real electron plus the vacuum
polarization of these virtual pairs it
picks up some of the compensating charge
from the positrons so this effect it
gives the net answer that there is
shielding of the electric charge and the
relationship of this to what we've been
talking about with cut-offs and so forth
is that if you think of these probes as
being at your cutoff scale the effective
value of the electric charge is
different with the cutoff if you are
sensitive to things at very high
energies the effective charge electron
is larger because it's not shielded as
it would be at low energies and you can
convert this into you know literally you
can plot the effective value of the
fine-structure constant 1 over 137 as a
function of the energy at which you
probe it and the fine-structure constant
goes up as the energy goes up so it's
not really a constant at all at higher
energies the fine-structure constant is
more than 137 1 over 137 this is true
for all of the different constants of
nature
well what's true is that they change
with energy scale some of them go down
the strong interactions have a feature
that they get weaker has energies go up
and that will be important later on so
and this is observed in experiments this
plot you can you can find this in the
particle data book which is the famous
book that collects all the different
examples of particle physics experiments
in the most modern form so all this
business about cut-offs and effective
theories up to some scale and the
renormalization group is not just
because we're weak and we're not able to
do things all the way up to the ultimate
high energy scales there's a physical
effect going on here when you really
probe quantum fields you're really
probing them at some scale and the scale
which you're probing them matters that's
where we normalization becomes very very
physical that's a nice little good news
picture so now I have some bad news and
you know look it's not really bad news
in some sense there's never truly
ultimately bad news in physics the bad
news is because we human beings have
trouble figuring out what the physical
world is doing but the world is doing
something okay there's not bad news in
the sense that physics doesn't make
sense again no one ever promised as a
Rose Garden it might be hard to figure
out what's happening in physics but
there are clues given to us by exactly
those things that we don't understand so
when I say bad news what I mean is right
now there's something we don't
understand maybe that has a clue to
something that is beyond our
understanding which we'll figure out and
then call as very good news and the
mystery is thing we don't understand
right now is the Higgs mass okay I don't
know if this was a you could have
noticed this along the way to what we
were already talking about I gave you
enough tools to figure this out what is
going on the Higgs boson which we
discovered in 2012 is a quantum field a
scalar field exactly like what we were
talking about here as I mentioned it has
a mass there's a mass term in the
Lagrangian for the Higgs field one-half
mass of the Higgs squared H squared
where H is the Higgs field itself okay
so we think that when we do experiments
with the Higgs boson like the Large
Hadron Collider we're not pretending to
understand physics at super high energy
scales we're using an effective field
theory with a cut-off but we think the
cutoff is a little bit higher you know
that we've measured the Higgs boson mass
to be about 125 GeV
billion electron volts we think the
cutoff should be a little bit bigger
than that and by the dimensional
analysis that we did we would expect you
know let's say let's say that we had
trust in the standard model of particle
physics well beyond where we've
experimental e tested it okay
let's imagine there is no new physics
beyond the standard model until we hit
quantum gravity or grand unification or
something like that in that case we
would say that I could imagine doing low
energy physics with a cut-off up at the
Planck scale I don't need to put it at
the electroweak scale if there's no new
physics okay so this is we're gonna have
two choices one choice is there's no new
physics and then I should be able to put
my cutoff way up of the Planck scale and
then in that case we would expect the
mass of the Higgs to be pushed up to the
cutoff and that should be a vorder the
Planck scale and that should be of order
10 to the 18 GeV if there were no new
physics above the electroweak scale
where the Higgs is above the Higgs scale
we should expect the mass of the Higgs
to be large it's an it's a relevant
operator that was our natural
expectation the whole point of the
effective field theory schpeel is that
we have natural expectations for the
values of these coupling constants but
it's not right 10 to the 18 is about 16
orders of magnitude bigger than the
actual pigs mass that we measure this is
called the hierarchy problem there's a
big hierarchy between the mass of the
Higgs or the electroweak scale more
generally because the mass of the W
boson and the Z boson which are also
part of collective weak Theory are also
of order 10 to the 2 GeV so there's huge
hierarchy between the electroweak scale
and the Planck scale if the electroweak
theory is an effective field theory and
nothing else happens up to the Planck
scale we should expect all those masses
to be up the Planck scale and they're
not okay so the other option is there is
new physics that would make us happy if
there is new physics to explain why the
mass of the Higgs is so much lighter
the mass in the plank mass or whatever
then that would imply that we should be
able to see it by doing experiments at
energies of order 10 to the 2 GeV so we
turned on the Large Hadron Collider in
2009 and we didn't see any new physics
other than the Higgs boson itself at
these energies supersymmetry is a famous
example of a set of new particles that
could have been found at the Large
Hadron Collider and would very naturally
have explained why the mass of the Higgs
was kept low even if we put our cutoff
up to very high values basically there
were cancellations in the Fineman
diagrams so the mass of the Higgs did
not get big but we didn't see
supersymmetry it was not the only
version of that theory you can have
large extra dimensions and other kinds
of theories Technicolor theories there's
a bunch of options for what new physics
at the electroweak scale could have been
to help explain why the mass of the
Higgs is small to help explain the
hierarchy problem but at least so far
and last decade or so of doing
experiments at the LHC we have not seen
any of them now it's always possible
that they've conspired to just hide
behind us I mean the the LHC is
wonderful as it is is not a super high
energy machine it's not as high energy
as the superconducting supercollider
that we wanted to build here in the
United States would have been if we'd
built that so maybe you know when the
LHC turns on again it'll be slightly
higher energy we'll see particles that
we didn't see before but the reality is
it would have been very easy to already
have seen particles at the LHC that
would help explain the hierarchy problem
and we haven't seen them so option one
was there's no new physics up to the
Planck scale and then in that case the
natural expectation of effective field
theory is the mass of the Higgs should
be the Planck scale that's not right
second option was there is new physics
near the elective weak scale near the
mass of things and we should see it at
the LHC tentatively it seems that's not
right either so what is the third option
what are we left with and the answer is
we don't know the answer is that it's
easy to say well we need something new
right we need a new paradigm we need to
go beyond quantum field theory and
chemical
an effective field theory and think
outside the box but it's hard to
actually do it right it's hard to
actually come up with a scheme that
explains why the mass of the Higgs is
what it is because effective field
theory has worked so well in other
contacts you can't just say effective
field theory is wrong you need to give
some principled reason for why it fails
in this particular case now having said
that let me be SuperDuper honest let me
sort of air the dirty laundry here
the Higgs mass or the hierarchy problem
that's a problem we have another problem
that we mentioned already the vacuum
energy ok the cosmati a constant problem
and this could be put into the language
of effective field theory the vacuum
energy can be thought of as a term in
the Lagrangian of the world and that
term is simply a constant with no fields
in it whatsoever okay so that term the
vacuum energy appears in Lagrangian as
just a number call it row lambda that's
what it is
and the units of Rho lambda Rho stands
for energy density lambda stands for the
vacuum the units of Rho lambda are
energy to the fourth better be energy to
the fourth because it's the same as the
Lagrangian city and therefore you expect
where you would guess that Rho lambda
should be of order the Planck mass 10 to
the 18 GeV to the fourth so just to get
my numbers correct that's 10 to the 27
electron volts to the fourth but then
you observe you actually measure it
right we have measured the vacuum energy
the cosmological constant and what do
you observe is Rho lambda is 10 to the
minus 3 electron volts to the fourth
power so this is a little bit more
sophisticated a little bit better than
what we did in the field theory lecture
in the field theory lecture we said look
there's an infinite contribution to the
vacuum energy we don't know what's going
on with that so on the one hand it was a
worse discrepancy infinity is bigger
than this discrepancy so this is where
we get
Rho lambda observed over Rho lambda
theory
let me not even call it theory let me be
more honest and call it gues expectation
is 10 to the minus 120 the largest
discrepancy between theory and
observation mole physics well we just
did the thinking of a quantum field as a
bunch of modes that were harmonic
oscillators and each of them had a
vacuum energy zero-point energy of 1/2 H
bar Omega it was an infinite difference
between the classical and the quantum of
values and so on the one hand you say
well infinity is bad but on the other
hand you say clearly we don't know what
we're talking about okay here the
numerical discrepancy is not as big it's
not infinitely big it's only 10 to 100
20 but on the other hand we would think
that we do know what we're talking about
now this is just the statement that you
know we don't need to know what happens
at ultra-high energies to know that
whatever happens they should contribute
to the low energy cosmological constant
and they should contribute a huge amount
and they don't and nobody knows why I
mean as I said it's so bad that the best
theory that we have is that we live in a
multiverse and there's different values
of the vacuum energy in different parts
of the multiverse that's not a good
theory it's not a very quantitative
predictive theory right now but it might
be right or it might be that there are
some other dramatic deviation from the
paradigm that needs to explain this and
the reason why I say I'm airing the
dirty laundry is I said that in fact the
field theories wonderful works really
well and that's true it's been used all
the time and it's been checked and we're
definitely on firm ground but in the
known theory of physics in the core
theory as I called it in the big picture
borrowing a phrase from Frank will check
of the standard model of particle
physics plus gravity there are only two
numbers that have that are not
dimensionless okay in the actual
lagrangian for the theory of physics
that we know there's a little subtlety
with the QCD scale for quantum
chromodynamics for the strong
interactions but that that that's
explained we understand that there are
two literal dimensional quantities that
appear in the physics that we know
the higgs mass and the cost marshal
constant those are the only two all the
other parameters like the fine-structure
constant are dimensionless and so we
have two dimensional parameters and in
both cases the effective field theory
gas or expectation is wildly wrong we
are Oh for two so there's many other I
keep emphasizing this there's many other
contexts in which effective field theory
works really really really well
so there's good reason to think is true
but for the case of giving us
expectations for the values of
dimensional parameters it has failed us
miserably in the real world and we don't
know why again it's cheap and easy to
say well the framework is wrong great
tell me what the right framework should
be you would make a lot of money here
you become a famous physicist if you
could actually say here's how we need to
do better it seems to be something where
you need to actually go beyond quantum
field theory but again that's easy to
say the energies for like the vacuum
energy the energy scale ten to minus 3
electron volts is really really low
that's lower than chemistry energies
this is in a regime where we think we
understand physics pretty well and
quantum field theory works pretty well
there needs to be this incredible
cancellation to get rid of all the
contributions from higher energy states
in the calculation of the vacuum energy
so once again good news and bad news bad
news is two big problems that we don't
understand the resolution to in the
effective field theory framework good
news is two big problems we don't
understand the resolution to we're in
this bad situation modern physics where
we don't have direct conflict conflict
between theory and experiment well we do
have are these naturalness problems
these fine-tuning problems right now
these problems are the best Clues we
have to going beyond the physics that we
know and love so it's important that we
love the physics we know and love it's
also important that we keep in mind how
best to go beyond